lettre à la république à tous et
racistes à la tolérance hypocrite qui
ont bâti leur nation sur le saint suaire
d'afrique comme ça ce passé colonial que
c'est faux des fous qui avait choisi de
lier votre histoire à la norme
tam est ici plus longtemps si j'ai toute
ma vie j'ai mon petit frère
j'ai ma mère est
puis l'entrée
la vie c'est une question de foi c'est
tout sauf que toi ton choix il a tué
papa c'est mon chien a tué par balle
j'en fais moi la paix et semoy le 3d m'a
dit je n'ai rien à voir avec toi
car ceci n'est pas une pas manqué de
parler je n'osais y va chercher jette
pas en plein bouquet lui l' issue le
même schéma kaelin je vais maintenant
vous révéler le sujet de votre débat
l'état est il seul responsable de la
situation actuelle des banlieues enfin
[Musique]
vous avez la parole
la banlieue je la connais lorsque deux
mauls a replongé dans le trafic de
drogue entre dans une pierre pour des
raisons strictement pécuniaires et que
cette guerre abouti à la mort de l'un
d'entre eux est ce l'état qui fournit
larmes à la sacem
lui ordonnent ou presque on voit mal qui
réduit sur la détente
thomert trop de jus commerce votre
hypocrisie d'eau